okay let's get started again so before I
proceed to Bayesian networks I'm gonna
talk about a few announcements so as you
probably know car is due tomorrow P
progress is due Thursday and then
finally the kind of big one is the exam
which is next Tuesday so everyone if
you're in the room or if you're watching
from home
please remember to go to the exam the
exam will cover all the material from
the beginning of the class up until and
including today's lecture so all
Bayesian networks no logic doesn't mean
you shouldn't use logic on the exam
reviews are going to be in Section this
Thursday and Saturday so you get not one
but two review sessions the first one
we'll talk about reflex and state based
models and the second mode talk about
variable widths models at this point all
the alternative exams have been
scheduled if you can't make the exam for
some reason then really please come talk
to us right now and just a final note is
that the exam is the problems are a
little bit different than the homework
problems they require more kind of
problem-solving and the best way to
prepare for the exam is to really go
through the old exams and get a sense
for what kind of problems and questions
you're going to be asked question where
is the Saturday session does anyone know
we don't know yet it will be posted on
Piazza any other questions about
anything
I know this is a lot of stuff but this
is probably going to be the busiest week
and then you get Thanksgiving break so
they'll be great okay so let's jump in
so two lectures ago we started
introducing a Bayesian networks so
Bayesian networks is a modeling paradigm
where you define a set of variables
which capture the state of the world and
you specify dependencies depicted as
directed edges between these variables
and given the graph structure then you
proceed to define distribution so first
you define a local conditional
distribution for every variable given
the parents so for example H given C and
a and I given a and then you slam all
these local conditional distributions
aka factors together and then find a
glorious joint distribution over all the
random variables okay and you think
about the Joint Distribution as the
source of all truth it is like a
probabilistic database a guru or Oracle
that can be used to answer queries so
this in the last lecture we talked about
algorithms for doing probablistic
inference where you're given a Bayesian
network which defines this glorious
joint distribution and your ass a number
of questions and questions look like
this condition on some evidence which is
a subset of the variables that you have
observed what is the distribution over
some other subset of the variables which
you didn't observe then we looked at a
number of different algorithms in the
last lecture there's a forward backward
algorithm which was useful for doing
filtering and smoothing queries in hmms
this was an exact algorithm then we
looked at particle filtering which
happens to be useful in the case where
your state space the number very odd
values that a variable can take on it
can be very large and this is an
approximate but in practice it tends to
be a good approximation and then finally
particle filtering which sorry and Gibbs
sampling which is this much more general
framework for doing probabilistic
inference in arbitrary factor graphs and
this was again approximate okay so so
far we've bit off two pieces
of this modeling inference learning
triangle we've talked about models we've
talked about inference algorithms and
finally today we're gonna talk about
learning and so the question in learning
as we've seen repeatedly throughout this
course is where did all the parameters
come from so so far we have assumed that
someone just hands you this these local
conditional distributions which are have
numbers filled out but in the real world
where do you get these and we're gonna
consider a setting where all of these
parameters are unknown and we have to
figure out what they are from data okay
so the roadmap we're gonna start first
start with supervised learning which is
going to be the kind of the easiest
easiest case and then we're going to
move to unsupervised learning where some
of the variables are going to be
unobserved okay so any questions before
we dive in okay let's do it so the
problem of learning is as follows we're
given training data and we want to turn
this into parameters okay so for the
specific instance of bayesian networks
training data looks like an example is
an assignment to all the variables okay
this will become clear in the example
and the parameters are all those local
conditional probabilities that we now
assume we don't know okay so here's a
question which is more computationally
more expensive for Bayesian networks is
it probabilistic inference given the
parameters or learning the parameters
given data so how many of you just use
your intuition how many of you think
it's the former problem inference is
more expensive okay one maybe how about
how many of you think learning is more
expensive yeah that's probably what you
would think right because learning seems
like there's just more unknowns and a
camp how can possibly be easier it turns
out that it's actually the opposite yeah
so good job and this will hopefully be a
relief to many of you because
I know probably the inference gets a
little bit quite intense sometimes and
learning will actually be maybe not
quite a walk in the park but it will be
a brisk stroll in the park and then when
we come back to unsupervised learning
it's gonna get hard again so at least in
the fully supervised setting it should
be easy and intuitive so what I'm gonna
do now is going to build up to the
general algorithm by a series of
examples of increasingly complex
Bayesian networks so here's the world's
simplest Bayesian network has one
variable in it let's assume that
variable represents the rating of a
movie so it takes on values 1 through 5
and to specify the local conditional
distribution you just have to specify
the probability of one the probability
of 2 the probability of three probably
four improbability five okay so these
five numbers represents the parameters
of the Bayesian network okay by fiddling
these I can get different distributions
okay so suppose someone hands you this
training data so it's fully observed
which means I observe one time I
preserve the value of R to be one the
second day I observe the value to be
three third day of observe it to be four
and so on
okay so this is your training data okay
so now the question is how do you go
from the training data here to the
parameters okay any ideas does use your
cut yeah count and then divide or
normalize okay so this is seems a very
natural intuition
later I'll justify why this is a
sensible thing to do but for now let's
just use your gut and see how far we can
get okay so the intuition is that the
probability of some value of ours should
be proportional to the number of times
it occurs in the training data so in
this particular example I look at all
the possible values of R 1 through 5 and
I just see one shows up once two shows
up zero times four shows up five times
and so on so these are the counts of the
particular values of R
and then I simply normalize okay so
normalization means adding the counts
together which gives you 10 and dividing
by 10 which gives you actual
probabilities okay it's pretty easy huh
yeah good okay so let's go to two
variables so now you improve your model
of ratings so now you take into account
the genre so as John Rizzo variable G
which can take on two values drama or
comedy and the rating is the same
variable as before and now let's draw
the simple Bayesian network which has
two variables and the local conditional
distributions are P of G and P of R
given G okay so again I'm going to give
you some training data which specify
each training example specifies a full
assignment to all the variables so in
this case it's D for D and this one it's
D for again
this one's c1 and so on and the
parameters here are the local
conditional distributions which is P of
G M P of our given G okay okay so let's
proceed to do this and here follow me
our nose again we're going to estimate
each local conditional distribution
separately okay so this is may not be
obvious why separate doing it separately
is the right thing to do but trust me it
is the right thing to do and certainly
is the easy thing to do so let's just do
that for now
okay so again look if we look at P of G
so we have to look at only this data
restricted to G and we see that D shows
up three times C shows up twice so I get
these counts and I normalize and that's
my estimate of the probability of G okay
and now let's look at the conditional
distribution our given G again I'm going
to count up the number of times that
these variables G and are show up so d4
shows up twice
d5 shows up once and so on count and
normalize
question and probability are our would
that cause any differences in the
results like if the order worked yeah
it's a good question so the question is
what happens if we define our model in
the opposite direction where we appeal R
and P of G given R so then you would be
estimating different probabilities UPS
many P of R which contains one through
five and then P of G given R which would
be a different table so the question is
if you do inference do you get the same
results in this case you will get the
same results in general you're not
you're depending on the the model you
define you're actually going to get a
different distribution which will lead
to different inference results yeah this
happens when you have two variables and
you couple them together and you do
things like this way you're effectively
estimating from the space of all joint
distributions G n R but we if you have
conditional independence and you have
for example hmm to order how you write
them all definitely affects what
inference is going to return okay all
right so so far so good so now let's add
another variable okay so so now we have
a variable a which represents whether a
movie one own award or not we're going
to draw this Bayesian network and the
joint distribution is P of G P of a P of
our given a and G okay so this type of
structure is called a V structure for
obvious reasons and this remember was
the thing that was tricky this is the
thing that leads to explaining away and
all sorts of tricky things in Bayesian
networks it turns out that when you're
doing learning in them it's actually the
all the trickery goes away okay so let's
just do the same thing as before so we
get this data each data point full
assignment to all the variable
so this is d 0 3 corresponds to g equals
d a equals 0 and R equals 3 and the
parameters are all again all the local
conditional distributions and now I'm
gonna count and normalize so this part
was the same as before counts and genres
D shows up three times seizures up twice
normalized a is treated very much the
same way so three movies have won no
Awards two movies have won one award so
the probability of movie Winnie Award is
two out of five and then finally this is
the local conditional distribution of
our given G and a and here we have to
specify for all combinations of all the
variables mentioned in that local
conditioner distribution I'm gonna count
the number of times that configuration
shows up so d01
shows up once right here d03 shows up
once right here and so on okay and now
when you normalize you just have to be
careful that you're normalizing only
over the variable that you're the local
distribution is on in this case R so for
every possible unique setting of GNA I
have a different distribution okay
so D 0 that's a distribution over 1 & 3
and if I normalize I get half and half
and each of these other ones are
completely separate because they have
different values of GNA okay any
questions
oh good alright so that wasn't too bad
so now let's invert the V and look at
this structure where now we have genre
there's no award variable but instead we
have two people radio movie and the
Bayesian network looks like this the
genre and we have our one given G and
our two given G and for now I'm going to
assume that these are different local
conditional distributions so I have P R
1 and P of R 2 so notice that in this
lecture I'm being very explicit about
the local conditional distribution here
I'm instead of just writing P of G which
can be ambiguous I'm writing PG to refer
to the fact that this is the local at
the conditional distribution for a
variable G this one's the one for R 1
this one for R 2 and those are different
and you'll see later why this this
matters okay so for now we're gonna go
through the same motions hopefully this
should be fairly intuitive by now you
simply count normalize for the P of G
and then for R 1 I'm just going to look
at the first or the second element here
which corresponds to R 1 and ignore our
two right so gr 1 so d 4 shows up twice
so i have d 4 and D for that shows up
twice d 5 shows up once
that's a d5c one shows up once and c 5
shows up once okay and then normalize
get my distribution and then same for r2
now ignoring R 1
I'm gonna look at how many times did G
equals D and R 2 equals 3 okay so you
can think about each of these is a kind
of a pattern that you sweep over the
training set so you have D 5 so that's a
1 here and d 4 that's a 1 here and D 3
that's a 1 here and so on and so forth
ok and then you normalize
okay how many of you are following this
okay cool alright so now things I'm
gonna make things a little bit more
interesting
so here I've defined different local
conditional distributions for each
rating variable r1 and r2 rights but in
general maybe I have r3 and r4 and r5
and have maybe a thousand people who are
rating this movie I don't really want to
have a separate very distribution for
each person so in this model I'm going
to define a single distribution over
rating conditioned on genre called PR
and this is where subscribing with the
actual identity of the local conditional
distribution becomes useful and this
allows us to distinguish PR from this
case which is PR one and PR 2 okay
notice that the the structure of the
graph remains the same so you can't tell
from just looking at the Bayesian
network you have to look at carefully at
the parameterization okay so if I just
have one PR what I'm going to do is what
do you think the right things should to
do is if you were just following your
nose I'm sorry yeah so count both of
them I think is what you're saying so
you combine them right so so P of G is
the same and now I'm going only have one
distribution I need to estimate here are
given G and I'm going to count the
number of times in the data where I'm
using I have a particular value of G and
a particular value of R okay and I'm
going to look at both R 1 and R 2 now
okay so D 3 shows up once here so that's
our
to d4 shows up three times so once here
with r1 once here with r1 and once here
with our two and so on
I'm not gonna go through all the details
and then you counted normalize another
way you can see this is that if I take
the counts from these two tables I'm
just kind of merging them adding them
together and then normalizing question
the ours are so is this assuming
something about independence here
so here when I'm doing I am assuming the
data points are independent first of all
and moreover I'm also assuming the
conditional independence structure of
the the Bayesian network is true so
conditioned on g r1 and r2 are
independent
yes so here I'm also assuming that r1
given G has the same distribution as r2
given G and this is part of the when I
define the model that way I'm no making
that assumption
okay so this is a general idea which I
want to call out which is called
parameter sharing and parameter sharing
is when the local conditional
distribution of different variables use
the same parameters so the way to think
about parameter sharing is in terms of
powering so you have this Bayesian
network it's hanging out here and behind
the scenes the parameters are kind of
driving it right and you can think about
the the parameters as these little
tables sitting out there and you connect
a table up to a variable if you say this
table is going to power on this node
okay so what parameter sharing in this
particular example is saying this
distribution of G powers this node and
these two variables r1 and r2 are going
to be powered by the same local
conditional distribution okay so okay
I'm gonna go to two more examples maybe
I'll draw them on the board to make this
a little bit more clear so remember the
naive Bayes model from two lectures ago
so this is a model that has a variable
that represents adapted to our movie
genre setting we have John reviewable
which takes on variable values comedy
and drama and then I have a movie review
which represents a document with L words
in it and each word is drawn
independently given Y so I have so in
the joint probability is therefore going
to be probability of genre Y times the
probability of WJ given Y for all words
Jade from 1 to L okay so so the way to
think about this graph the Bayesian
networks is you have a variable Y here
and so I'm just going to draw with w1w
- w3 and I'm going to have a local
conditional distribution here which is
why P genre of Y so that's some table
that's powering this node and then I
have a separate one single other
variable
sorry local conditional distribution of
doublets y Y and W and probability of
what I call it word word W given Y and
this distribution powers these variables
okay so notice that here there's two
local conditional distributions we have
genre and we have word even though there
are L plus one variables in the Bayesian
network yeah yeah so the input water so
the question is what is the input to P
word W given Y so it when you apply this
to a particular variable in some sense
you bind why - why
and you bind W to the particular WI at
hand when W
and you can see this kind of
mathematically where you here we have
you pass into the P word W J given Y and
J ranges from 1 to L just to kind of
solidify understanding let me ask the
following question if Y can take on two
values as in here and each word can take
on D values how many parameters are
there in other words how many numbers
are in these two tables on the board so
shout out the answer
okay so 2d plus news so there's two here
right so they're CG there's two numbers
and then they're for every C there's D
possible values for D there's D possible
values so there's two plus so there's
two here and then there's D plus D here
okay now if you really want to be fancy
and count the number of rama's you
really need it should be less than this
because if I specify the probability of
C then you can 1 minus that probability
is probably D but let's not worry about
that okay let's do the same thing for
hmm s just to make sure we're on the
same page here since we all love hmm
okay so in hmm remember there's a
sequence of hidden variables H 1 H 2 H 3
and for each hidden variable we have e1
e2 and e3 which are the observed
variables and there are 3 types of
distributions for each amounts there is
the probability of I'm going to call P
start of H which is going to specify the
initial distribution over h1 I'm going
to have the transition probabilities
which I'm going to denote age
it's called eighth prime probability of
H prime should write down P trans here H
prime given H so this is going to be
another distribution which powers each
transition each non initial hidden
variable okay remember these are
pointing
two variables not edges or anything else
and finally I'm going to have a
distribution the mission distribution of
e given each that table is going to
power each of observed variable Z okay
and here again there are three types of
distributions start transition in
emission even though there could be any
number of variables in actual Bayesian
network okay and just to be very clear
about this when I apply this table to
this node H binds to H 1 and H 2 H prime
binds to H 2 and then when I apply it to
this node H 2 binds to H and H prime
binds to H 3 and again you can see this
from the formulas where I'm passing in
to P trans H I given H I minus 1 as I
sweeps from 2 to n ok so you can think
about this is like a little function
with local variables the argument to
that that function are H and H prime but
when I actually called this function so
to speak when defining a Joint
Distribution I'm passing in the actual
variables of the Bayesian network
okay any questions about this okay maybe
just summarize some concepts first okay
so we talked about learning as the
generically the problem of how we go
from data to parameters and data in this
case is full assignments to all the
random variables in the hmm case it's a
data point is a assignment to all the
hidden variables and the observed
variables and parameters usually denoted
theta is all the local conditional
distributions which are these three
tables in the case of hmm okay the key
intuition is count and normalize which
is intuitive and later I'll justify why
this is an appropriate way to do
parameter estimation and then finally
parameter sharing is this idea which
allows you to define huge Bayesian
networks but not have to blow up the
number of parameters because you can
share the parameters between the
different variables okay
so now let's talk about the general case
so hopefully you kind of understand the
basic intuition so this is just going to
be some abstract notation that's gonna
kind of sum it up so in a general
Bayesian network we have variables X 1
through X and and we're gonna say that
parameters are a collection of
distributions so theta equals P a sub D
ok and so Big D is going to be the set
of types of distributions so in the hmm
case it's going to be three types start
trans and omit so basically that's the
number of these little boxes that I have
on the board are and the Joint
Distribution when you define a Bayesian
network is going to be
the product of P of X i given X parents
of I so this is the same as we had
before but now notice the crucial
difference which I've outlined in red
here is that I'm subscribing this p with
a di okay so what di for the ithe
variable says is which of these
distributions is powering that variable
okay
so D of this variable is omit D of this
variable is transition and D of this
variable is start okay so this is looks
maybe a little bit abstract and
notationally but the idea is just to
multiply in the probability is that was
used to generate that a variable or
power that variable okay and parameter
measuring just means that di could be
the same for multiple eyes yep model
case wish the emission probabilities are
all the same
like why do we need multiple missions
it's like we're going to be the same
it's just drawing from the same
distribution three times yes so the
question is if we only have one emission
distribution why do we need so many of
these replica copies and the reason is
that these variables represent the
objects locations at a particular time
so the value of this is going to be
different based on what time step you're
at but the mechanism for generating that
variable is the same just like if I
flipped a coin you know ten times I only
have one distribution that represents
the probability of heads but I have ten
realizations of that random variable
another analogy might be helpful is
think about really well these as like a
primitive like functions in your program
that you can call right this is like a
sorting function and sorting is just
used in a whole bunch of different
places but it's kind of the same kind of
local function that powers a bunch of
different use cases which are specific
to the context yeah okay so in this
general notation what is the learning
look like so the training data is a set
of four assignments and I want to output
the parameters so here's the the basic
form its Celt and normalized
so in counting there's just a bunch of
for loops so for each training example
which is X is a full assignment and I'm
going to look at every variable I'm
going to just increment a counter which
of the DI
distribution of this particular
configuration X parents I and X I okay
and then in the normalization step I'm
going to consider all the different
types of distributions and then I'm
going to consider all the possible local
assignments to the parents
and I'm going to normalize that
distribution yeah yes so the DI refers
for the I variable which read table I'm
looking at
okay so I've given you already a bunch
of examples
so hopefully this the notation might be
a little bit loose but hopefully you
guys already have the you know intuition
any questions moving on the main point
of this slide is just to say that this
is actually very general and I just
didn't do it for hidden Markov models
now you phase-in it doesn't work for
anything else okay so now let me come
back to the question of you know why
does count and normalize make sense
right so this is kind of normalize this
is like you know some made-up procedure
so why is it a reasonable thing to do
and it turns out this is actually based
on very firm kind of foundational
principles this idea of maximum
likelihood which is an idea from
statistics that says if I see some data
and I have a model over that data I want
to tweak the parameters to make the
probability of that data as high as
possible okay so in symbols what this
looks like is I want to find the
parameters theta
so remember parameters are probabilities
in the red tables on the board and then
I'm going to look at make the product of
all over all the training examples the
probability of that assignment so for
every possible setting of the parameters
I can a stat assigns particular
probabilities to my training examples
and I want to make that number as high
as possible okay and the point is that
the algorithm on previous lie exactly
computes this maximum likely so the
parameters in closed form so which is
really nice if you think about when we
talk about machine learning we define a
loss function and you can't compute
anything in closed form except for maybe
linear regression and you have to use
stochastic gradient descent to optimize
it here it's actually much simpler
because of the way that the model is set
up
you just counted normalize and that is
actually the optimal answer so just
because you write down a max doesn't
always mean you have to use gradient
descent is a lesson here okay so let me
I'm not gonna prove this in generality
but I want to give you some intuition
why this is true and hopefully connect
the kind of the abstract principle with
on the ground algorithm that you of
counter normalizing so suppose we have a
two variable Bayesian network with genre
and rating so I have three data points
here and I have this maximum likelihood
principle which I'm no going to follow
and let's do some algebra here so I'm
going to expand the Joint Distribution
and remember Joint Distribution is just
the product of all the local conditional
distributions and I've also expanded
this you know the product over these
three instances so I have the
probability of D probably a for given D
probability of D here probably a v given
D probably of C I'm probably a v given C
okay and what I'm maximizing over here
right now is a distribution of Roshanara
and I have a distribution of rating
conditioned on genre as C and the
distribution of rating condition genre
equals D okay so I've color-coded these
in a certain way to emphasize that that
all the red touches is is the local
conditional distribution corresponding
genre the blue is corresponds to
probability of rating given genre codes
D and green is probably of rating given
genre Cosi okay so now I can shuffle
things around okay
and I notice that these factors don't
actually depend on probability of G at
all so they can just hang out over here
and I've essentially and and this
likewise on
if I'm thinking about the maximum over
you know argument see these other
factors are just constant so don't
really matter either
so I basically reduce this as a problem
of three independent maximization
problems okay and this is why I could
take each local conditional distribution
in turn and do count and normalize on
each one separately okay so and then the
rest is actually you know to do it
actually properly you have to use
Lagrange multipliers to to solve it but
intuitively hopefully you can either do
that or just believe that if I ask you
what is the probability best way to set
probabilities so that this quantity is
maximized I'm going to set probability
of D equals 2/3 and probably if C equals
1/3 this is similar to one of the
questions on the Foundation's homework
if you not remember oh but only for a
probability of a coin flip it
essentially okay so hopefully some of
you can now rest you know sleep at night
thinking that if you do count and
normalize you're actually obeying some
high-minded principle of maximum
likelihood okay so let's talk about
Allah plus smoothing so here's a
scenario if I have give you a coin and I
said I don't know its probability of
heads but you flip it a hundred times
and 23 times its heads and seventy-seven
times its Hale's what is the maximum
likelihood estimate going to be
yeah so it's going to be probably of
heads is you know counting normalize its
23 over 100 which is 0.23 probably if
tails is point seven seven okay
so seems reasonable right so what about
this so you flip a coin once and you get
heads what's the probability of heads so
the maximum likelihood says 1 & 0 so you
know some of you are probably thinking
you know smiling and probably thinking
this is a very closed-minded thing to do
right just because you saw one has it's
like oh okay
the probability of heads must be one
tails is impossible because I never saw
it so seems pretty you know foolish and
intuitively you feel like well tails
might happen you know sometimes so it
shouldn't be as stark as 1 0 okay and
this is an example of overfitting which
we talked about in the machine learning
lecture where maximum likelihood will
tend to just maximize the probability
and here it does maximize the
probability because the probability of
data is now 1 and you can't do better
than that
but this is definitely overfitting so we
want a more reasonable estimate
so this is where Laplace smoothing comes
in and again I'm going to introduce the
plus smoothing from kind of a fall your
nose kind of framework and then I'll
talk about why it might be a good idea
okay so here's maximum likelihood just a
number of times head occurs over a total
number of trials you have so Laplace
smoothing is just adding some numbers so
look this is applause named after the
famous French mathematician who did a
lot more than add numbers like applause
transform and well plus distribution but
we're only going to use to talk about
his adding numbers invention I guess so
so here in red I'm shown that for this
problem estimate no matter what the data
is I'm just going
out of one here I don't care what the
data looks I'm just gonna add a one I'm
gonna divide by the total number of
values are which are possible which is
two heads or tails and four tails I'm
also gonna add a 1 I don't care what the
data says and I'm gonna divide by two
okay so now I get 2/3 and 1/3 which
should be a more you know sensible
intuitively sensible estimate if you're
gonna come up with any sort of estimate
it says well I saw heads so probably
more than 50% it's going to be heads but
it's probably not you know 100% ok so
let's look at it in a slightly more
complicated settings so here I have two
variables and Laplace smoothing is
driven by a parameter of lambda which by
default is going to be one but it can be
any number non-negative number and what
the plus moving amounts to is saying
start out with your tables and instead
of filling them with zero fill them with
lambda okay so here's my table before I
even look at the data I'm just going to
put ones down and then when I look at my
data I'm just going to add to that
counter so D shows up twice C shows up
once and then accounting normalize okay
same over here before any look at any
data I'm just going to populate with
ones which is lambda and then I get my
three data points and I add the three
counters which are shown here in a
counter normalize so by construction no
event should have probability 0 unless m
to 0 because I already start with one
and one divided by some positive number
is not zero okay so the general idea is
for every distribution impartial
assignment I'm going to add lambda to
that count you know and then I'm just
going to normalize
to get the probability estimates okay
so the interpretation of Laplace
smoothing is you're essentially you know
pretending that you saw lambda
occurrences of every local assignment
even though you didn't see in your data
you're hallucinating this this data
sometimes it's called pseudo counts or
virtual counts and the more higher
lambda is the more hallucination or more
smoothing you're doing and that will
draw the probabilities closer to the
uniform distribution and the other
extreme lambda equals zero is simply
maximum likelihood but in the end you
know data wins out so if you had Laplace
moving and you saw one head and now
you're saying estimating the probability
to two-thirds but suppose you keep on
flipping this coin and it keeps on
coming up heads 998 times then by doing
the same Laplace smoothing you're going
to eventually update your probability
for 0.999 you're never going to reach 1
exactly because no probabilities are
going to be ever 0 1 but increasingly
you're going to be much more confident
that this is a very very brave coin
ok any questions about Laplace me so
what plus smoothing is just add lambda
to everything essentially and oh so I
forgot the principle behind Laplace
smoothie is if you think in terms of
this is kind of beyond the scope of this
course but you can think about a prior
distribution over your parameters which
is some uniform distribution and instead
of doing maximum likelihood you're doing
map or Mac maximum a pastori
estimation so there is another principle
but you don't have to worry about it for
this class yeah the question is how big
do you make lambda it's a good question
so one is lambda should be small it
probably shouldn't be like 100 probably
should be more like 1 or even you can
make it less than 1 maybe it's trivial
like point 0 1 or something depends on
you know how I guess uncertain you know
where you are
so in general that these priors are
meant to capture what you know about the
kind of the distribution okay all right
so now we get to the fun part on this is
going to in some sense combine learning
which we've done with probabilistic
inference which we did before and the
motivation here is that what happens if
you don't observe some of the variables
so far learning has assumed that we
observe complete assignments to all the
random variables but in practice this is
just not true right the whole reason
people call them kidding Markov model is
is that you don't actually observe the
hidden States so what happens if we only
get observations or in this simpler
example what happens if the data looks
like this where
observe the ratings but we don't observe
their genres so what can you do
so obviously the count and normalized
thing doesn't work anymore because you
can't count with question marks so there
is again two ways to think about what to
do here the high-minded principle is
appeal to maximum likelihood and make it
work for unobserved variables and the
other way to think about it which I'll
come to later is simply guess what the
latent variables are and then do count
and normalize okay and those these two
are going to be equivalent so let's be
high-minded for now and think about what
maximum marginal likelihood okay so in
general we're going to think about H as
the hidden variables and E is observed
variables in this case G is hidden and
r1 and r2 are observed and suppose I see
some evidence e so I see r1 equals 1 r2
equals 2 but I don't see the value of G
and again the parameter is all the same
as same as before I just have less data
or information to estimate the
parameters okay so if you're following
maximum likelihood what is maximum
likelihood say it says tweak the
parameters so that the likelihood of
your data is as large as possible so
what is the likelihood of the data here
it's simply instead of H and E I have
probability of E okay so this seems like
a kind of a very natural sound extension
of maximum likelihood and it's called
maximum marginal likelihood because this
quantity is a marginal likelihood right
it's not a joint likelihood or joint
distributions as a marginal distribution
over only a subset of the variables okay
so now to unpack this a bit
what is this marginal distribution it's
actually by
axioms of probability it's the summation
over all possible values of the hidden
variables of the Joint Distribution so
in other words you can think about
maximum marginal likelihood is saying I
want to change the parameters in such a
way that such that the probability of
what I see as high as possible but what
that really requires me to do is think
about all the possible values that H
could take on I don't see it so I have
to consider what ifs what if it were see
what if you were D and so on okay so in
other words fundamentally if you don't
observe a variable you have to consider
possible values of them all right so now
let's skip to the other side the kind of
a scrappy way and think about what is a
reasonable algorithm that makes sense
and I'm not gonna have time in this
course to kind of show the formal
connection but if you take you know CS
228 or a graphical modest class it will
go into this in much more detail so the
intuition here is the same as what we
had for k-means
so remember in k-means you tried to do
clustering you don't know the the
centroids and you also don't know the
assignments so you it's a
chicken-and-egg problem so you go back
and forth between figuring out what the
centroids are and figuring out what the
assignments are and the centroids are
going to be an analog of parameters here
and assignments are going to be the
analog of the hidden variables okay
so here's here's algorithm
it's called expectation maximization it
was no formalized in its generality and
in the 70s and you start out with some
parameters maybe initializing to uniform
or uniform plus a little bit noise and
then it's going to alt we're going to
alternate between two steps that each
step and the M step and
you it's useful to think about the
k-means in your head while you're coming
through this algorithm so in each step
we're going to guess what the hidden
variables are or what the values of the
hidden variables take on so we're going
to define this Q of H which is going to
be or represent our guests and since
we're in probability land we're going to
consider the distribution over a
possible values of H and this guess is
going to be given by our current setting
of parameters and the evidence that
we've observed in our fixing so we're
asking the question what is the
probability of the hidden variables
taking on particular values of H given
my data and given my parameters so this
should this should look kind of familiar
to you right what is this there's just
probabilistic inference right which
we've been doing for the last lecture
which means that you can use any problem
sick inference algorithm here you can do
forward backward you can do gibbs
sampling and that's kind of a sub-module
that you need to do i'm am ok ok so now
what happens if we have our setting of
or guess over the possible values H now
we make up data so we create weighted
points of with particular values of H
and E and each of them gets some weight
q of H and then finally once we're given
these weigh two points now we're just
going to use do count and normalize and
do maximum likelihood ok so I'm going to
walk through an example to make this a
little bit more grounded out so I'm
going to do this on a board because it's
gonna get a little bit
maybe a little bit hairy okay let's
let's do this
so here we have a three variable
[Music]
Bayesian so we have let's draw it over
here actually might need a space so we
have G we have r1 and r2 okay and our
data that we see is we get data which is
two two and one two okay so I observe
two two that's one data point and one
two that's another data point okay so
initially what I'm going to do is start
with some setting of parameters okay
so I'm going to start with my parameters
theta which specify a distribution over
G and for lack of information I'm going
to consider just half and half let me
write point five to be consistent so I'm
initializing unit with a uniform
distribution and my other table here is
going to be G and R so probability of
our given G and here I have seen the
possible values of G and the possible
values R which for simplicity I'm going
to assume to just be one and two and
then for this I have for these numbers
0.4 0.6 and 0.6 0.4 so I'm I'm not
sending them to uniform but adding a
little bit of noise so hopefully people
can check that I'm the numbers on the
board are the same as the numbers on the
slides okay so so that's my initial
parameter setting so now in the e step
I'm gonna use these parameters and to
guess what G is okay so what does this
look like
so for each possible data point so for
every example so I have two two that's
one data point I'm gonna try to guess
what the value of G is so it could be C
it could be D and for the other data
point one two it's also could be C or
could be D okay and now I'm going to try
to compute a weight for each of these
data points based on the model okay so
the weight is not now look look at this
this is cool right because I have a
complete assignment and you know what to
do with complete assignments I can just
evaluate the probability of that
assignment okay so now just just to make
things concrete I have positive G times
probability of r1 given G probability of
our - given G this is by definition the
probability of G so this is Joint
Distribution by definition of this
evasion Network it's this okay so how do
i compute the probability of this
configuration well it's a probability of
G equals C so I look at this table that
can be 0.5 times the probability of r1
given G that's 2 and C so if you look
over here
that's a 0.6 and then another r2 given G
that's also a 2 and a C so that's 0.6
which has a parameter sharing and that's
a point 1 age right let me to slide so
you guys can check my work ok so now I
look at this table
so probably ability of G equals D is 0.5
and then the probability of r1 equals to
given G equals D
well if look in this table that's 0.4
and then I have another point for from
another two and that is 0.08 and then I
can normalize this question DQ versus
weight six for c2 so why is this point
four versus point six here this is
because I initialize the parameters so
that the probability of R equals two
Givens G equals D is point four why did
I use this internationalization just for
fun I just made it up
just so that if I had put point fives
here then you couldn't really tell what
was going on and also as a side market
wouldn't you know work initialization is
generally going to be random but as
close to uniform as as possible yeah
okay so this is this is a column is
going to be the probability of basically
G equals G R r1 equals r1 r2 equals r2
okay and then the Q is going to just be
is just going to be the weight of this
and normalizing these two which means
you add them up and you divide and then
you get was a point six nine and three
one sorry the numbers are a little bit
kind of awkward but that's what you get
there I'm not going to do the second
roll but it's it's basically the same
type of calculation question Asian kind
of like particle filtering in that like
because step you do like the proposal
and then waiting and then
that is like the recent resampling like
finding them accident the question is is
each and expectation-maximization
because you have this proposal when
you're waiting structurally it's quite
different I mean there is a sense like
if there are some they're proposing
different options but certainly the two
algorithms are meant to solve very
different tasks one is for learning or
one is for probabilistic inference yeah
okay so let's look at the m-step now
okay so the m-step I'll let you guys
fill this end so the m-step I actually
want to keep this up let me do that I'm
step over here is going to now just take
these examples so these weights are
point five so it's it's like someone
handed you fully labeled data complete
observations for points but each of
observation has a weight so now the only
difference to encounter normalized
instead of just adding one whenever you
see a particular completists
configuration you're gonna add the
weight okay so for each of the
parameters I'm going to look at so this
is going to be G probability of G so
this can be either C or D and to get
this I have let me first do the count
yes well okay let me just add it here so
I look at my data so let me mark this so
this is now my kind of I'm gonna put
data in quotes because I didn't actually
observe it I just hallucinating it and
these are the weights which are
associated with the data points so now
I'm going to look at yes look at G
equals C so I see see here see here and
I have the weights point six nine
six nine plus point five probability of
so you just count and then for D I see a
D here and I see a D here that's point
three one plus 0.5 and then I normalize
this and I get my estimate okay so on
the slide this is exactly what I did
here I count and normalize and I'm gonna
and I'm gonna do this table by you
hopefully get the idea yep yes so in the
each step you have to estimate for all
possible assignments to H so in this
case H is only one variable in the next
example H is going to be in a hidden
Markov model all the variables and we're
gonna see how we can deal with that yeah
playing briefly how we get the values in
the second table the second table which
this one this one yeah yeah sure just
briefly so you look at these data points
and you see c1 okay so where does c1
show up so G equals C here R 1 equals 1
here so that's a point 5 here and then
what about C 2 where does C to show up C
2 shows up twice here with R 1 and R 2
so that's why there's two of point six
9s here and C two shows up once here
with a weight of 0.5 yeah everything
here these counts are based on the table
from
okay all right so let's do something a
little bit fun now
so the copula cipher is this 105 page
encrypted volume that was discovered and
people dated back from the 1730's so it
looks like this
so it's unreadable because it's actually
a cipher it's not meant to be it just
read and for decades people are trying
to figure out you know what is the
actual message that was inside this text
it's a lot of text and and finally in
2011 some researchers actually crack
this code and they actually use e/m to
help do this so I'm going to give you a
kind of a toy version of using a.m. to
do decipherment and it turns out that
this code is basically some book from a
secret society which you can go read
about on Wikipedia if you want
so substitution ciphers a substitution
cipher consists of a substitution table
which specifies for every letter assume
we have only 26 right now
a cipher letter okay and the way you
apply a substitution table is you take a
plain text which generally is unknown if
you're trying to decipher like let's say
hello world and you look up each letter
in the substitution table and you write
down the corresponding thing so H maps
to n so you write n e maps to M so you
write down to M and so on and so someone
did this and then they obviously didn't
give you the plaintext they give you the
ciphertext and so now all you have is a
ciphertext and obviously didn't give you
the substitution table either so you all
you have is the ciphertext and you're
trying to figure out both the cipher a
substitution table and also the
plaintext okay so hopefully this pattern
matches something and let's try to model
this as a hidden Markov model okay so
here the hidden variables are going to
be the characters in the plaintext this
is actual sequence that the hello world
and then observations are the characters
of the ciphertext so familiar equation
the Joint Distribution of the hidden
Markov model is given by this equation
and we want to estimate the parameters
which include P star P trans and p.m. it
okay so how do we go about doing this so
we're going to approach this in a in a
slightly different way I guess then
simply just running the algorithm
because we have additional structure
here right so the probability of start I
have no idea which is just set it to
uniform the the probability of
transition so this is interesting so
normally if you're doing M you don't
know the problem of transition but
because we know let's say we know that
the underlying text was English we can
actually estimate the probability of a
war character given a previous English
character from just English text lying
around so this is cool because it allows
us to hopefully simplify the problem I
should maybe comment that in general and
supervised learning is really really
hard and just because you can write down
a bunch of equations doesn't mean
that'll work and it's very hard to get
it to work so you want to get as much
kind of supervision or information as
you can ok so finally e p.m. it is the
substitution table which we're going to
derive from yeah ok so now this might
not type check in your head because a
substitution specifies for every letter
one other letter the cipher letter but
in order to fit it into this framework
we're going to think about a
distribution over possible cipher
letters given a plaintext letter okay
with the intention that well you know if
it's doing its job it can always
put a probability 1 on the actual cipher
letter okay
so just you know set me back away from
the formulism why might you think this
could work and in general this is not
obvious that it should work but but what
what you have here is a language model P
transition which tells you kind of what
plaintext looks like right if you
generated a cipher and you say yeah this
is my cipher and you get some garbage
that it's probably not right so we have
some information about what we're
looking for like so like when you solve
a puzzle you know when you kind of
solved it and then finally we also have
this omission that tells us that each
letter that E has to go to kind of be
substituted in the same way so you can't
have you going to you know different
completely different things at different
points at the time okay so so for doing
estimation hmm we're going to use the
EMF Witham and remember in the estep
we're just doing probabilistic inference
and we saw that forward-backward it
gives us probably stick inference in
particular it gives you for every
position I'm going to give you my guess
which is a distribution of our possible
hidden variables so remember I each
position eyes observe the cipher letter
and I'm going to guess a distribution
over the plaintext letter okay and then
the m-step I'm just going to count and
normalize as we did before
so once I've guessed the cipher letters
I can just compute the probability of
some cipher letter given a plaintext
letter okay so I'm actually going to
code this up and see it so you can see
it in action okay I only have five
minutes here so to make this quick okay
so here we have cipher text okay looks
pretty good we're gonna decrypt this or
decipher it and then we also have our
text which is just some English text
that we found and then I'm going to I
want to decipher an island cipher okay
so there's some utilities which are
going to be useful so things for reading
texts converting them things into
integers normalization of weight and
then most importantly this
implementation of a forward backward
algorithm which we're going to use okay
because I'm not going to try to do that
in five minutes
okay so let's initialize the hmm and
then later we're gonna run them on it
okay so the hmm parameters are there's
going to be start probability which is P
in our notation probability of start and
this is going to be 1 over the number of
possible letters here for this is just a
uniform distribution 1 over K and I
should say K is 26 plus 1 so this is
lowercase letters plus space okay so now
we have our transition probabilities and
I'm going to this is going to define a
distribution over hidden variable an X
hidden variable given previous hidden
variable and notice that the order is
reversed here because I want to first
condition on h1 and then this thing is
going to be a distribution so to do this
I'm going to first remember my
strategies I'm gonna use the language
model data
to count so I'm going to have again set
things to 0 for H 2 inch range K for h1
and range KITT so this basically gives
me a matrix of K by K matrix of all
zeros and now I'm going to get my raw
text and I'm going to read it from
train which remember looks like this and
I'm gonna convert this into a sequence
of integers where they're going to be 0
to K minus 1 and then I'm going to how
do i estimate the transition again
Calton normalize so I'm going to go
through this sequence and and I'm going
to count every successive transition
from one character to another and I'm
going to so I'm going to add position I
I have a character which is brought X of
I at position I plus 1 I have another
character h2 and I'm just going to
increment this count
okay and finally I'm going to normalize
this distribution so transition probably
calls so for every h1 I have I have a
transition counts of h1 and I can call
the helpful normalize function which
takes this distribution and normalizes
it ok so this is just doing fully
observed to maximum likelihood count
normalize on just the plain text okay
all right so now emission probs this is
going to be probability of emit of a
given H and I'm going to just initialize
these to uniform because I don't know
any better so 1 over K for ian's range K
for range K so just it happens that both
that hidden variables and observed
variables have the same domain that's
not generally the case okay so now I'm
ready to run yeah
so can it do two hundred iterations just
just put in a number so have the e step
in the m-step so in the east step
remember I'm going to do probabilistic
inference I'm going to call forward
backward and remember this is this is
going to be basically in our notation at
the position I what is my distribution
over hidden States so this is actually
forward backward oh I need to read some
observations I read my ciphertext
ciphertext and I'm going to convert this
again into an integer array and then I
have observations and then I pass in the
parameters of my hidden Markov model and
then I have my gas so let me print out
what that guess is okay so what I'm
going to do here is for every position
I'm going to get the most likely outcome
of each so util of arc max of Q I for I
in range length of observations okay so
that gives me an array of guesses for
each position and then I'm gonna convert
that into a string so it's easier to
look at and put in your line so this is
printing the best guess okay so finally
for the m-step I'm going I have my Q
which gives me counts so now I pretend I
have a lot of you know data which are
weighted by Q so I'm going to have
emission counts equal as same as before
I'm just going to get a matrix of zeros
even range k4h and ring
okay and then I'm going to go through
the sequence from I equals range of see
the length of the observation sequence
and for each position in the sequence
I'm going to consider all the possible
possible plaintext hidden values and I'm
going to increment H observations of I
so this is the observation that I
actually saw and this should be qi h
which is the weight of 8 h at position i
okay and then finally I'm just going to
normalize so like what I did well okay
I've just normalize that here so
emission probabilities is util dot
normalize of the counts for H and range
okay okay
and I think that's pretty much it let me
see if this okay this should be for for
what right okay okay good okay so let's
run this and then I'll go back to there
let me just look over the code just one
more time
okay so so we initialize the the
probabilities to uniform for transition
probabilities we can use the
observations or the just a plain text we
just count and normalize in emissions we
initialize with uniform and then what
running am we read the cipher text and
then in the east step we're going to use
the current problem parameters to guess
where the cipher text is and then we're
going to update our estimate of what the
parameters are given our guess of what
the cipher text is
okay so here's the final truth the
ciphertext and so remember each
iteration it's going to print out the
best guess so it will look like
gibberish for a little bit it's not
gonna be perfect
but this is starts to look somewhat like
English there's a hand and in my in
there anyone can read this alone without
okay that looks like English maybe this
is like anyone that I could you want to
guess what this text is so here's the
plain text so I've lived my life alone
without anyone that I could really talk
to until I had I'm accident with my
plane and the does with my whatever
something but but so again unsupervised
learning doesn't it's not magic it
doesn't always work but here you at
least see some signal and in the actual
application they got partway there and
then you can iterate on this man kind of
in a man your way okay
all right so that's for it for Bayesian
networks on Wednesday with your logic